[Musik]
eines dieser bilder zeigt das
u-bahn-netz der millionenstadt tokio
das andere das werk eines einzeller das
eine wurde über jahrzehnte akribisch
geplant aufgebaut und bei bedarf
angepasst dass andere entstand weil
dieser schleimpilz hier hunger hatte
wissenschaftler haben haferflocken auf
eine kleine 17 cm große karte der stadt
tokio gelegt und 26 stunden gewartet bis
der schleimpilz alle nahrungsquellen auf
die effizienteste art und weise
miteinander verbunden hatte und das
ergebnis sieht der stadt tokio ziemlich
ähnlich keine leichte aufgabe vor allem
für ein lebewesen das gar kein gehirn
hat was natürlich die frage aufwirft
braucht man eigentlich hin um
intelligent zu sein
[Musik]
das hier ist dr christina meier sie
arbeitet am institut für biophysik der
universität bremen im team von professor
doktor hans günter dubber einer und
untersucht dort schon seit vielen jahren
den schleim ps bzw
warum politik fallen wie er offiziell
heißt also schleimpilze sind weder
pflanzen noch tiere noch pilze obwohl
der deutsche name schleimpilze klingt ja
eigentlich eher so nach pils aber es
sind keine pilze sondern ist tatsächlich
einzellige kleine amöben und wo man die
findet ist meistens sie kommt im wald
vor die zersetzende totes organisches
material also runter gefallen baumstämme
oder blätter oder auch andere echte
pilze fressen die auch und leben dann so
im wald also die lebensweise kann man
fast mit der von pilzen vergleichen
wenn man sich jetzt jedes andere tier
pflanze was auch immer anguckt und
selber uns uns menschen
wir bestehen aus einzelnen zellen also
unsere gewebe sind aus 110 zellen
aufgebaut für die zellen sind wie
bausteine für uns also aus ganz vielen
zellen wird ein großes liebe wer seinen
organismus aber ein schleimpilz ist
tatsächlich eine zelle weil der eine
zellmembran besitzt und in dem
zytoplasma also in dem inhalt von der
zelle sind aber ganz ganz viele
zellkerne
also das ist wirklich nur eine zelle hat
aber sehr viel zellkern und kann
deswegen auch so groß werden also die
können bis zu 1 2 quadratmeter sogar
groß werden und es ist trotzdem immer
noch eine zelle und die hat sogar ihren
einzug ins guinness buch der rekorde
gefunden als die größte zelle die es
gibt
das ist natürlich ein bisschen
geschummelt jederzeit herren hat seinen
zytoplasma bereich sowie bei uns jede
zelle ihren kleinen bereich hat aber was
dem schleimpilz von uns unterscheidet
ist dass es keine zellwände gibt nichts
ist voneinander getrennt und so kann
ganz leicht ein austausch von zytoplasma
stattfinden
das sieht man wenn man sich dem
schleimpilz im zeitraffer ansieht er
pulsiert es fließt eine strömung durch
ihn hindurch
aber was macht so ein steinpilz
eigentlich der kann sich fortbewegen
will kann netzwerke bilden der kann nach
nahrung suchen der kriegt im wald herum
und muss irgendwie nahrung finden und er
vermeidet auch bestimmte bereiche wie
zum beispiel ist zu viel licht gibt und
wo es zu trocken ist dann möchte ich
gerne sein von daher kriegt er dann
lieber weg er vermeidet das dann so was
hier faszinierend finden ist was für ein
repertoire an verhalten der eigentlich
hat
also wie viele spannende sachen der
schleimpilz kann wo man eigentlich der
gefühl dass das kann ja gar nicht können
er hat keine beine keine zähne keine
augen und trotzdem kann der sachen
machen die eigentlich viel
kompliziertere lebewesen so auf die
reihe kriegen können
obwohl der schleimpilz kein gehirn hat
kann man eine reihe erstaunlicher
experimente mit ihm durchführen
so kann er sich zum beispiel an dinge
erinnern wenn man für warum einem
unangenehmen reiz aus setzt zum beispiel
trockene luft dann reagiert er darauf
indem er sich zusammenzieht
das verringert seine oberfläche und soll
verhindern dass er austrocknet wenn man
diesen luftstoß in regelmäßigen
abständen gibt zum beispiel einmal pro
stunde
dann erinnert sich der schleimpilz daran
und zieht sich bereits vor dem nächsten
luftstoß wieder zusammen so als würde er
erwarten vielleicht wieder von trockener
luft getroffen zu werden wenn der reiz
allerdings ausbleibt verfügt der
schleimpilz weiterhin seine
abwehrmaßnahmen
diese wird lima schwächer je häufiger
der luftstoß ausbleibt wenn dann nach
sechs stunden aber wieder einen luft
schuss kommt ist der rhythmus des
einstündigen abstands sofort wieder da
er hat sich die frequenz gemerkt und
wenn man so will ein gedächtnis ohne
gehirn der schleimpilz findet auch den
kürzesten weg durch ein labyrinth egal
wie kompliziert das labyrinth ist ohne
augen oder eine nase findet ihr immer
die optimale route um zwei
nahrungsquellen miteinander zu verbinden
wobei das auf eine ganz andere art und
weise macht als wir menschen der
schleimpilz führt zuerst das ganze
labyrinth aus jede ecke und jede
sackgasse bisher alle nahrungsquellen
gefunden hat dann zieht er sich zurück
und lässt nur die kürzeste verbindung
zwischen diesen beiden punkten bestehen
mit derselben methode hat der steinpilz
auch das netzwerk von tokio nach gebaut
da er immer gefahr läuft auszutrocknen
möchte er seine oberfläche minimieren
der schleimpilz verbindet also mehrere
nahrungsquellen auf die kürzest mögliche
art und weise miteinander
eine aufgabe die für einen einzeller
ziemlich beeindruckend ist selbst
computer müssen bei der effizienten
verbindung mehrerer punkte schon recht
lange rechnern der schleimpilz macht das
einfach mal so eine lustige anekdote
vielleicht wir haben einmal so eine
jugend forscht schüler die hier gehabt
die hier ein paar versuche gemacht haben
für ihre jugend forscht beteiligung und
die haben auch so dieses experiment
produziert mit bremen wir sind ja hier
in bremen
es gibt noch die schwierigkeit dass wir
ihn natürlich einfluss haben denn wir
durch die stadt läuft und
wenige brücken das heißt wenn man den
nord- und südteil der stadt verbinden
wir muss man immer über so eine brücke
und die habe er gesehen dass der schleim
wird an einer stelle die weser überquert
hatte im umfeld dieses jugend forscht
wettbewerbs war tatsächlich auch jemand
von der stadt da die die infrastruktur
planen und die haben gesagt oh das ist
ja interessant an der stelle überquert
ist die weser ja wir haben darüber
nachgedacht ob da vielleicht eine neue
brücke hin sollte der schleimpilz kann
sogar dramatisch sein ist er nämlich
kurz vor dem verhungern und weiß nicht
woher die nächste nahrungsquelle film
wird dann begeht er eine
verzweiflungstat
er teilt sich in mehrere teile auf und
schickt sie in unterschiedliche
himmelsrichtungen wohl wissend dass die
meisten seiner teile
vielleicht nicht überleben werden aber
das ist okay denn solange ein teil
überlebt überlebt auch der ganze
schleimpilz denn es ist ja nur eine
zelle und der schleimpilz hat sogar
selbstheilende fähigkeiten wenn sich
zwei getrennte schleimpilze wiederfinden
dann können sie sich auch wieder ganz
schnell zusammensetzen
die forscher des teams in bremen
befassen sich unter anderem mit
entscheidungen von physarum polycephalum
untersucht wird zum beispiel wie der
schleimpilz sich verhält wenn er hunger
hat und auf ein hindernis trifft der
experiment aufbau ist ich habe hier eine
futterquelle aber hier so eine barriere
aus salz und hier ist der schleimpilz
und er hat hunger
und dann weiß der durch jemand taxis
dass da hinten das futter ist aber er
weiß dass ohne so eine brücke so eine
barriere von salz und da sieht man
tatsächlich was man nicht anders als
zögerliches verhalten beschreiben kann
es ist nicht so dass der da hingeht und
sagt nee geht nicht weil salz kann ich
nicht rüber und das ist auch nicht so
dass er das einfach ignoriert und
darüber kriegt und zum futter zu
kinderland ist man ein und derselbe
schleimpilz nähert sich auf dieser
barriere an
versucht mal dann zieht er sich wieder
zurück dann guckt kann ich doch
vielleicht am rand vorbei geht auch
nicht ja gut also wirklich zögerliches
verhalten schon fast und das ist ja
wirklich das ist ein so menschlicher
begriffs und das widerspricht eigentlich
komplett dieser idee die es auch
eigentlich schon ein bisschen alt aber
dass man immer gesagt hat wir sind ja
nur ja so was wie biologische computer
wir sind dazu programmiert alles zu
machen
ich habe hunger ich sehe essen ich esse
je mehr ich über diesen schleimpilz
erfahrung desto mehr kommt bei mir die
frage auf ist der schleimpilz wirklich
intelligent auf der einen seite muss man
natürlich vorsichtig sein dass man da
nicht anthropomorphe wird dass man nicht
seinen eigenen menschlichen empfindungen
darauf projiziert aber auf der anderen
seite ist es natürlich ganz logisch wie
bei jedem anderen lebewesen auch bekommt
er eben welche input aus der umwelt in
welche reize nimmt er war der kann licht
wahrnehmen aber auch chemikalien also
sein futter ist zum beispiel kann der
riechen sozusagen und diese reize werden
im inneren der zelle irgendwie
verarbeitet und hinterher hat man einen
gewissen output also das verhalten was
man beobachten kann
aber wie macht der schleimpilz das wie
kann er ohne gehirn denken und
entscheidungen treffen
ja also wir haben uns auch das ganze
netzwerk an sich angeguckt und die
dynamik davon also was man jetzt nicht
sieht wenn man einfach nur den stempel
sich so anschaut da laufen tatsächlich
solche wellen über die oberfläche und
zwar dicke wählen die dicke des
schleimpilze variiert weil er ja
oszilliert die ganze zeit so setzt sich
immer zusammen diese adern kontrollieren
und weiten sich wieder auf und das haben
jetzt angeguckt auf dem großen netzwerk
die schleimpilze und man kann eben das
in schönen bunten farben sichtbar machen
welche bereiche mit derselben phase
oszillieren wie andere
und da haben wir große muster gesehen
also große muster wie spiral wählen oder
einfach so ein flackern so hin und her
im oszillieren da kann man tatsächlich
auch überlegen wo in der biologie habe
ich noch sowas und solche koordinierten
wellenmuster kann man auch feststellen
wenn man die elektrische aktivität des
gehirns zb sichtbar macht meine
vermutung ist dass in dieser oszillation
eine information drinsteckt
informationen informationsverarbeitung
intelligenz der begriff intelligenz ist
natürlich stark durch uns menschen
geprägt wir nehmen uns selbst als
messlatte für alle anderen lebewesen
unser bewusstsein entsteht durch
elektrische aktivität im gehirn unsere
nervenzellen sind miteinander verbunden
und ob zwischen zwei nervenzellen strom
fließt oder nicht trägt eine information
beim schleimpilz gibt es keine
nervenzellen und keinen strom sondern
hydrodynamische wellen die oszillation
womit sich die meisten wahrscheinlich
anfreunden können ist zu sagen
bewusstsein kommission und so weiter
entsteht aus dem zusammenspiel der
neuronen in unserem gehirn da ist kein
kleines tisches geheimnis dabei oder so
das sind zellen die miteinander
interagieren
die sind total hoch vernetzt und
kommunizieren miteinander erzeugen muss
da die über das ganze gehirn laufen
haben lokale aktivitäten und so weiter
kann jetzt neurobiologe wahrscheinlich
mehr zu sagen aber alles weitere was
dann entsteht unser bewusstsein muss ein
produkt davon seien und wenn etwas sehr
sehr stark vernetzt ist hat man ein sehr
hohes niveau der komplexität und da
rauskommen daneben eigenschaften die in
jeder einzelnen nervenzelle nicht zu
finden sind auch nicht nur im kleinen
hier nur im präfrontalen kortex nur in
anderen gegen region sondern die aus dem
zusammenspiel der ganzen komponenten
entsteht
das ist im ergänzt und das ist dann eben
intelligenz und beim schleimpilz stelle
ich mir das auch so ähnlich vor ich habe
ja schon gesagt dass die für eine
einzelne zelle eine hohe komplexität hat
nicht nur was er alles kann was man an
verhalten beobachten kann sondern auch
die ja ich hab mir jetzt wirklich
genauer angeguckt und
elektronenmikroskopische aufnahmen
gemacht für us-cents mikroskopie ich
habe mir die struktur von dem
zytoskelett angeguckt also die proteine
die dafür sorgen dass der schlamm fühlt
sich bewegen kann das sehr herumkriechen
kann und das genom des pilzes ist auch
mittlerweile entschlüsselt das heißt man
hat festgestellt die haben ein
erstaunlich hohes maß an intrazellulären
signalwegen also rezeptoren die
irgendwas von von außen wahrnehmen in
welchen reiz und das dann in der zelle
weiterleiten also irgendwelche proteinen
reaktions kaskaden die dann ablaufen und
irgendetwas bewirken
also im vergleich zu anderen
vergleichbaren organismen auf der auf
der gleichen evolutionsstufe ist das
recht ausgefeilt und sehr sehr sehr
ausgeprägt wie gesagt keiner behauptet
jetzt ein schleimpilz ist nimmt seine
umwelt genauso wahr wie christina oder
wie cedrick sondern der der schleimpilz
wird irgendeine form der kondition haben
aber natürlich nicht so hoch entwickelt
wenn wir gerade gesagt haben intelligenz
im gehirn ist das zusammenspiel von
vielen nervenzellen die komplizierte
sachen machen und das ganze ist dann
mehr als die summe der teile
dann würde ich sagen wir haben nicht die
nervenzellen als substrat wo drauf das
abläuft also als die hardware so kann
man sich das vielleicht vorstellen
sondern wer im schleimpilz was andere
und nur weil die keine nervenzellen
haben heißt das aber nicht dass diese
prozesse dieses netzwerken diese
verschaltungen er nicht auch stattfinden
die frage aller fragen ist jetzt ist es
wichtig auf welcher hardware unsere
software läuft oder muss man nur das
richtige ergebnis auswerfen um schlau zu
sein und ab wann findet intelligenz über
hauptstadt entsteht intelligenz dadurch
dass besonders viele verschaltungen
existieren und informationen verarbeitet
werden sind wir mehr als nur die summe
unserer teile die gibt es natürlich tief
in die philosophie hinein und deswegen
habe ich christina mal gefragt was ihre
meinung dazu ist der schleimpilz ist
auch definitiv smart würde ich sagen das
ist der ist schlau und er hat zelluläre
intelligenz also am anfang hatte ich
mich damit auseinander gesetzt habe war
ich überhaupt nicht der meinung ich
hatte insgeheim immer gedacht nein wenn
man intelligent ist also das ist einfach
ne gehirn basierte sache man braucht ein
gehirn umzudenken um schlau zu sein
ich denke da werden wir wahrscheinlich
auch viele zustimmen aber je mehr ich
mich damit auseinander gesetzt haben je
mehr ich wirklich gesehen habe zu was
der schleimpilz in der lage ist was der
alles kann was für einen
verhaltensrepertoire der hat wieder
angepasst ist dass der problem lösen
kann und so weiter desto mehr denke ich
er aber vielleicht muss man die
intelligenz begriff überdenken
juli ist die frage das würde ich gerne
an euch weitergeben wie würdet ihr
intelligenz definieren unterscheidet uns
etwas vom schleim pils oder seid ihr der
meinung dass es eigentlich egal ist wie
informationen verarbeitet werden solange
das ergebnis stimmt schreibt sie mir
gerne unten in die kommentare
vielen lieben dank an das forscherteam
aus bremen die uns beim dreh unterstützt
haben die uns alles gezeigt haben die
uns die türen geöffnet haben und mit
denen wir coole interviews drehen
durften vielen lieben dank an dich
christina vielen lieben dank an
professor doktor hans günter dubber
einer vielen dank an euch fürs zuschauen
wenn ihr mehr solcher videos sehen wollt
wo wir wirklich hinfahren und forscher
interviewen dann überlegt euch doch mal
ob wir uns auf kathrin unterstützen
wollten das ist für uns wirklich eine
tolle möglichkeit noch mal zusätzlich
sachen möglich zu machen
deswegen jetzt schon mal viel lieben
dank an alle leute die uns heute schon
auf patrick
stützen ansonsten wie immer bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]